The areas that IBM is taking this,
and that we've concentrated
on is in health care.
And you may be aware that we've
created a Watson Health Group.
An entire organization dedicated
to leveraging cognitive computing
technologies for the benefit of
improving the medical practice and
the health system.
It includes everything from,
as I suggested earlier,
being able to determine
the best treatments for
in college with patients based on
clinical evidence, clinical literature.
Includes being able to help technicians
do a better job of diagnosing
a patient's symptoms through
medical imaging, right?
To be able to look at a medical image,
an MRI or
x-ray and recognize in that x-ray,
within that image
the anomalies that would represent
key issues with that patient.
And oftentimes,
the level of resolution and
clarity that even our own human
eyes not able to really pick up on.
So healthcare is a big area.
We're now focusing on
the Internet of Things.
If we think about all of
the data coming in from
all the devices that
are deployed in our world today.
Whether that's the information is coming
off our cars and where we drive to or
how we drive or the condition of
the car itself, out on oil rigs.
And all the machinery this deploy there.
In our homes and
the sensors that we have for
taking temperature readings or
ambient air quality readings.
On and on and on, all these sensors
are generating data that in
aggregate are hard to assimilate,
hard to understand.
And it's hard to derive any inspiration.
Given sort of the diversity information
and sort of all the noise, if you will,
that exists within that data.
So be apply a cognitive system, to be
able to look at all the signals and
be able to derive meaning.
And out of that meaning
derive insight and
inspiration that now allows us to
think about what we should be doing?
How should we be responding
if we are on our oil rig and
our responsibility is to
maintain the equipment on that.
How do we prepare for
that maintenance by evaluating the
information coming in all these signals?
For in our home,
how do we make decisions and
how do we get inspired by, how we can in
fact live better and more comfortably?
If we're in a car, is there a better
way of getting to where we need to be,
or be able to do that in a more
convenient and a safe way?
Those are areas that we within
IBM are concentrating on.
Again, if we look at our ecosystem, the
number of areas that they're focusing on
is enormous, it's diverse, it's just
about everything that you can imagine,
in our life, In our human experience.
There's an opportunity for
an application to be brought to that and
enhance it in some meaningful
way to make us more powerful,
to make us able as humans,
to make better decisions or
to be able to consider information
that today is just overwhelming.
There's just too much of it and
we can't simulate it all.
And to be able to identify that,
if you will connect the dots, all right?
To find the associations and all
the data that we would otherwise miss.
Either because we don't have time to
read it all, which generally we don't.
Or even more so, even if we did
read it all, we have biases, right?
And those biases causes
to filter out real
information that exists, that if we saw
it we would be able to make use of.
The way that pharmacists, or people in
the pharmacological research industry.
People who are responsible for
coming up with new drugs.
Most often than not,
it's not about creating a new compound.
It's never been found before or
considered before, but
it's about finding new applications of
already known compounds to solving for
new medical problems.
And a lot of that is about
connecting the dots.
It's about finding the research paper or
the patent or the other sources of
literature where this compound had been
discussed had been evaluated but often
in a field that is completely unrelated
to the thing that I care about, that
allows me to get an idea that eventually
leads to, perhaps a new drug discovery.